oué match y est en plein essor de
nouveau jumelé et des mini maison pouces
60 nouvelles habitations sont attendus
et on projette la construction d'une
auberge d'une piscine et d'une maison
des aînés adobe c'est de finir de
finition extérieure d éliminer
habitations là il va avoir d'autres jobs
à l'intérieur d'affiner aux et l'egypte
c'est ce que j'ai suivi le couple
[Musique]
l'an dernier à pareille date
jean philippe p tit coup et était sur
les bancs d'école le centre de formation
qualitech offert une formation en
charpenterie-menuiserie dans la
communauté
une première chez les attikameks 20 des
21 élèves ont obtenu leur diplôme en
juin dernier après quoi ils ont tous
trouvé du boulot
jean philippe et deux de ses camarades
de classe bâtisse les nouvelles maisons
une façon pour wim empêché de réduire la
surpopulation dans les logements sa part
soit les gens locaux qui ont les revenus
autres que chômage est bien et
socialement on sent on sent qu'à une
fierté
on sent que que l'argent et où la
communauté aussi bien les petits coups
et lui a été engagé comme ouvrier si des
hydro québec mène une vie et une ville
bien mené ce sont les conditions
salariales et le régime de retraite
qu'ils ont attiré est aussitôt qu'ils
ont dit qu'à la salade de basses est à
26 44
ça m'a vraiment intéressé avec de bons
avantages sociaux cas de bain le sait
que cette formation soit fr dans sa
communauté a tout changé
si pour offrir d'autres cours d'autres
formations
un peu partout des communautés c'est ce
que les communautés avant cela powell au
lieu de tout temps
traîner la patte comme on dit hydro
québec dont l'un des objectifs est
d'augmenter la représentativité des
premières nations au sein de ses
employés abonde dans le même sens
mécanicien l'appareillage électricien
d'appareillage sont des métiers qui
demandent quand même une formation
environ demandé me dit maman envergure
effectivement ça pourrait faire déborder
boucher puis on espère que l'on va
pouvoir répéter l'expérience avec
d'autres
d'autres candidats par la suite jean
philippe n'a pas fini d'apprendre
il veut obtenir sa licence
d'entrepreneur général fait travailler
du mobile pour et d'autres contre eux
pour aller travailler à l'extérieur je
ce pauvre et si devenir son propre
patron et simone montambault radio
canada oui menthe hachée